Cái cối, biển hiệu đồ giặc sẽ tại bị gió quật lật ngang khi báo cá hào đổ bộ và đất liền chú khuốc.
Báo đổ bộ khu vực chết rằng chở chính tháng tám, với sự gió gần tâm báo khoảng 1,5 km,
kém người lớn 2,5 mươi đến 1,5 mươi tả nhiều khu vực miền đông chú khuốc.
Chúng tâm khi tượng khuốc ra chục khuốc đã phát kẹn bảo đỏ, mất cao nhất trong hệ thống kẹn bảo báo,
hơn một chưởng người tại các khu vực chữ anh hưởng đã được sơ tán.
Tại thận 2, nhiều khu vực nập sâu,
hay xanh bay của thành phố khí tâm cộng chính chăm 4,5 mươi truyến bay gió anh hưởng của báo,
làm giảng công sức khai thác gần 4,5 mươi.
Quảng 12 giờ sau khi độ bộ, báo suy yếu thành áp thấp nhận đối và giữa kiến dí chuyển về phía tay,
mang theo người lớn đến bắc kinh, thiên tân, hả bắc và liều ninh, mùi cơ gây lũ luật và sật lợn.
Chức khi và Trung Quốc báo cá hèo đã gây nâng bơ dông và lúc sống tại này đoàn khiến sống người bị thơ.
Đây là kinh bảo thứ 18, độ bộ Trung Quốc trong năm nay và cũng là kinh bảo mạnh nhất từ đầu năm.
Một số khu vực phán biển chết rằng được dự báo có thể gây nhận lượng bơ,
2,5 mươi đến 4,5 mươi miệng miệng miệng miệng miệng.